IT'S NOT LIKE YOU GUYS WANT
TO FIX THE SYSTEM.
>> Tucker: I THINK OUR
VIEWERS CAN DETERMINE
WHETHER
WHERHER
WHEREER
WHEREYOU ARE COMING FROM, JOSE.
THANK YOU.
>> THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
>> Tucker: MARK STEYN IS A
COLUMNIST AND BY THE WAY
IMGRANTED WE WILL LET HIM
SAY WHETHER HIS LAND WAS ANY
AND MAYBE THE PRESIDENT SAID
SOME THINGS I DIDN'T HEAR
SAYING LOOK, WHAT WHY WOULD
WE GIVE PREFERENCE TO POOR
COUNTRIES OVER RICH ONES?
THAT DOESN'T SEEM LIKE A
CRAZY THING TO SAY.
>> I THINK IS HE ACTUALLY
SAYING WHY SHOULD WE GIVE
PREFERENCE TO DYSFUNCTIONAL
SOCIETIES OVER OTHERS?
I WILL SAY IT IN JOSE WON'T.
50 YEARS AGO EVERY NATION
THOUGHT IT HAD THE RIGHT TO
DISCRIMINATE WHEN IT CAME TO
ASSIMILATE AND CONTRIBUTE TO
THE COUNTRY THEY WERE MOVING
TO.
IF JOSE THINKS YOU DON'T
LIKE BLACK PEOPLE OR BROWN
PEOPLE, LET'S KEEP IT ALL
THE PATIENT I WISH HE WOULD
HAVE FORM LATHED IT MORE.
HAITI IS A [BLEEP] HOLE.
GRENADE ISN'T.
ST. LUCIA ISN'T.
THERE ARE DISTINCTIONS ONE
CAN MAKE EVEN WITHIN SMALL
GROUPS OF COUNTRIES AS TO
JOAN WALSH REFUSING TO SAY
WHETHER SHE WOULD RATHER
MOVE TO MATEY OR NORWAY.
TRAFFIC THERE ARE IMMIGRANTS
ALL OVER THE WORLD WHO MOVES
TO NORWAY.
WHY IS THAT?
IT'S A DYSFUNCTIONAL SOCIETY
PRESENT LUDICROUS SYSTEM
TAKES NEWCOMERS FROM.
>> Tucker: SO CHINA IS THE
MOST AGGRESSIVE COLONIAL
POWER IN THE WORLD RIGHT NOW
AND IT'S INVESTING ALL OVER
AFRICA AND ALL OVER LATIN
AMERICA AND ALL OVER THE
CARIBBEAN.
SPENDING $30 BILLION IN
HAITI, FOR EXAMPLE.
THERE IS NO PRESSURE FROM
JOAN WALSH OR THE AMERICAN
LEFT.
THE CHINESE TO ABSORB
THEY ARE NOT DENOUNCED AS
RACIST FOR KEEPING THEIR
BORDERS TOTALLY CLOSED TO
EVERYBODY.
WHY IS THAT?
INTERESTS.
SO IT'S BOUGHT, FOR EXAMPLE,
A BIG BOX INDUSTRY IN
JAMAICA.
IT DOESN'T FEEL ALONG WITH
THAT IT HAS TO IMPORT A BIG
BUNCH OF JAMAICANS TO ITS
PEOPLE CAN OBJECT TO WHAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP SAYS.
BUT IT ACTUALLY MAKES FAR
MORE SENSE THAN IF YOU LOOK
AT WHAT PAT LEAHY SAID WHO
JUST SENT OUT THIS TWEET IN
RESPONSE BLEEPING THAT'S NOT
WHO WE ARE.
IT'S NOT ENOUGH TO ACTUALLY
SAY THAT'S NOT WHO WE ARE.
AND, IN FACT, THAT'S THE
RESPONSE TO EVERYONE OF
THESE SO-CALLED PROBLEMS.
THAT'S NOT WHO WE ARE.
THEY NEVER ACTUALLY SAY WHO
WE ARE.
THAT'S THAT'S NOT WHO WE'RE.
WHO WE ARE SEEMS TO BE
DEVOLVING INTO THE PEOPLE
WHO SAY THAT'S NOT WHO WE
ARE.
EVERYBODY ELSE, CHINA,
HAITI, NORWAY IS ALLOWED TO
BE WHO WE ARE AND ACT AS A
NATION IN ITS OWN NATIONAL
INTERESTS.
INCLUDING ON IMMIGRATION
POLICY.
>> Tucker: YEAH.
I THINK CHINA COULD USE A
LITTLE MORE DIVERSITY.